with so much bad news around these days
many of you might feel it's a
fairly gloomy festive season this year
we'll let you
hold the bus for a minute and introduce
you to jeremy
vogs now when jeremy says he's putting
up the decorations
you're gonna have to brace yourselves
and jeremy and of course
the better half as well mandy we should
not forget of course and
i think guys it's it's fair to say
christmas has become
rather a special time of year for you
both isn't it
oh it certainly has yes yeah drags on
for a few months now actually so
um but yeah we love doing it so drags on
for a few months we
viewers will be wondering why well let
me show you why guys if we just take a
little
look at the lights display that we have
it is a thing of beauty amazement
and some incredible size i had 150 000
bulbs perhaps used in this do you have a
more accurate and up-to-date figure
no we actually we never really thought
about how sort of big it was but
when we were asked the other day i
guessed at 40 000 and i thought no it
can't be anything
because another's one tree you've got 10
000 on it so
uh i spent a day adding them all up and
we got just short of 150 000
so um mandy who is the driving force
behind all of this i'm just wondering
whether it's the long-suffering wife
that's that that's tolerating the
husband or
is you as bad as he is
oh no no it's all him he's on him i'm
just a good
i'm just the gopher jeremy take us back
to the beginning how on earth did you
get started on this quest to
to be well the only kind of home in
england visible from space
it's um we just started we removed the
house
we were putting a new roof on it there
was some scaffolding on the front and we
just put a few lights on it for the kids
is a bit of a joke
and it just sort of went slightly bigger
each year
and then nine years ago we started
fundraising for the nspcc and that sort
of gave us a license to
uh well give me a license to do a little
bit more then
and it and it's just sort of grown every
year how long does it take
to get this display up and running it's
not a couple of days it's not a weekend
job for you i'm presuming
no we start in uh october getting the
garden ready putting frames up and that
sort of thing
and then the lights start going up in uh
november
and it took 26 full days i'll take a
fortnight off work in november
um and then we spend
well they're up till twelfth night so
keep them going and running
and then we start taking them down and i
aim to have them all packed away by
easter
by easter fantastic mandy i don't know
why you're smiling i'm going to ask you
directly do you not have any neighbors
no no we don't please but you do
presumably
you do presumably have an energy
provider i'm wondering how the bill's
looking
well they rubbed their hands i think
it's well
yeah it's something we're conscious of
and uh we do use a supplier that's 100
renewable so
um that sort of makes it feel a bit a
bit better and we're switching them all
over to leds now as well
so it's you know uses a lot less now
yeah fantastic um
is it true that the raf use your house
uh during the festive period as a
navigation beacon
yes somebody uh bumped into us at the
local show
and they said that a pilot had told them
to tell us that
um they through december they love it
because it's
easy it stands out um they tried using
blackpool but they kept getting lost
so uh they use hours now i'm
just just on on a slightly serious note
and looking at the pictures i'm sure i
saw
a rainbow um put up there you're kind of
reflecting the year that we've had i'm
presuming in
in the decorations
yes yes jeremy and our daughter jess
they uh painstakingly made that
themselves so yeah it was very good for
the nhs and key workers
thought it was a good thing to do yeah i
i don't think you guys will be alone in
going slightly over the top this year in
terms of christmas people have been
you know stuck in their houses for
extended periods of time we've all had a
little wobble from time to time i'm sure
um but displays like this i mean
obviously the planning is great
the charitable donations even better but
just to look
up and see such a sight really must
bring a bit of cheer a bit of festive
cheer to those that
live within 10 15 20 miles of you
yeah we weren't really sure when we sort
of started whether we were going to be
able to do it this year or not but
because we had to start back in october
we made a start and we got so much
encouragement from all the locals
walking past they're saying how pleased
they were
because we took a year off last year we
didn't do it last year so we've just
brought it back to
cheer everybody up for the because of
the bad year they've had
um and yeah i mean people are saying
that
you know they can safely bring their
grandparents etc can drive
past um and just stop in the car and
look and it's just cheering everybody up
so um just one last word and it has to
go to mandy i'm afraid who has
been remarkable not just during this
interview but perhaps over the past
20 years that you've been doing this i
mean mandy do you see it stopping
anytime soon
no no i don't think so
i don't know it's up to him we might we
might have to do it every couple of
years rather than every year i think
but we'll see yeah i i think jeremy
reading between the lines there you know
i think
mandy is keeping this one under review
very much like a government
minister on the program this morning
keeping her exactly yes yes you have to
be cautious
make promises you can't keep uh well
it's been an absolute pleasure to chat
to you both uh mandate jeremy lovely to
have you on the program
and uh